you may remember last time this is two
days ago you started to look at and
that's in quantities like actual amount
of stuff like leaders of this or this
many centimeters or people or tickets or
all kinds of objects that can be
measured quantified we looked at these
and then we thought about well what if
you could take a fraction or percentage
of these amounts and quantities that's
what you looked at last time okay so
it's like alright I've got eight pieces
of pizza in my pizza what if I wanted to
eat such and such a percentage of that
having pieces would that be okay so
we're still in the same idea today but
we're going to go in the other direction
right when you've got an amount or
quantity which is some fraction or
percentage or something else like okay I
ate three of the eight pieces of pizza
what percentage would that represent
okay so we're kind of going in the other
direction this morning let's have a look
if you open up to page 228 229 is where
you'll find in today's exercise on the
road through a couple of examples with
you but I'll start and I'll put this all
over the right hand side so that it
stays there and we can refer to it when
you are addressing these kinds of
questions I'm gonna give you sort of
four general style tips which will
always be really really helpful for you
okay
for tips so I'd love you to write these
down before you start your exercise or
even do your examples because when we do
the examples you'll see how useful these
tips are so tip number one I'm just
gonna do like the UM the most simple
boiled down definition here but I'll
give you a full sentence and I'll
explain and then the examples it'll all
make sense when it comes together okay
so the first tip is read the questions
really really carefully read the
question carefully it doesn't take long
to realize we're talking about stuff
objects about real physical things and
you can see it in the questions
everything is very wordy right
I'm the technical way of saying that
this is that they're very literacy
you gotta interpret you got to
understand the language it makes all the
difference to you understand the
question and then answering it rightly
or wrongly based on whether you have
looked carefully at the language give it
to you the question and if you know what
it means because to this tip number one
read really carefully okay tip number
two is kind of like the opposite there's
so many words there that's why you have
to read carefully but because there's so
many words of the question you ought to
use words in your answer write your
answers to all of these kinds of
questions shouldn't just be a series of
numbers and equations you probably can
get the right-hand side
just with the numbers in equations this
is maths after all but in order to be
able to communicate clearly what your
numbers and equations actually mean and
then get a right answer out of it you
should be using words in the actual
formation and working of your question
which is what I'll show you okay
speaking of working I mean we've said
this before but please include all your
work you I'm gonna emphasize it again
this time because a lot of what we're
gonna be doing like their ikki
percentages and fractions right so you
will obviously rely on a calculator for
big plots of answering the question by
the way if you haven't already got it
out you should get your calculator
because you'll need it for these
questions now for a large number of
these questions you might be able to do
all of the working on here because
they're wonderfully powerful tools but
you shouldn't even if you use the
calculator for the whole question you
should never think I don't each include
all my working when I'm writing it
you're still about communicating how I
got the answer so yes we'll be using our
calculators but we should be including
all the working that we're thinking
through on the page last tip because you
know for example if I said oh yeah I ate
three pieces of pizza right out of eight
okay you're gonna get a percentage out
of that often the percentages will have
many many decimal places or the
fractions will be kind of awkward okay
so you'll have to approximate at some
point is my last year
it's at the end because the place you
should approximate is at the end you may
have to approximately take oh you know
three pieces of pizza out of eight I
think is 37.5% if I wanted that to the
nearest percent you did that right at
the very end it's your last step
actually to approximate okay don't
approximate early because whenever you
approximate you change things a little
bit if I did to the nearest percent
thirty seven point five would be where
to round up or down it will round up to
38 wouldn't it cause quickfires right on
that point which we decided goes up so
38 percent I've introduced half a
percent of error okay so that error if I
don't do it at the end it's gonna flow
on to the rest of my working so don't do
it at the beginning do it at the end